hmm  are people getting hotter  no they're getting colder and no one  knows why nearly 200 years ago Carl  Reinhold August Wonderlic observed that  98.6 37 was the average temperature of  the human body but every year since that  observation each new crop of people born  has wound up running on average about  three thousandths of a degree celsius  cooler than those born the year before  today adults run at an average of about  97.5  36.4 and we don't know what's causing it  could be that we're all walking around  with less infection and inflammation  than before because of better hygiene  medicine sanitation food water but that  doesn't explain why even the indigenous  cemain of Bolivia are also cooling down  all we know right now is that  scientifically speaking boomers are  hotter than millennials